from Puppet penetration to a soldier who
swears more than a sailor I knew this
was an episode I shouldn't have watched
with my mom episode 6 of genv V is here
that will have us questioning what Dean
shed's real plan with the woods is
golden boy's secret blood transfusion
the true extent of Kate's power and what
the hell happened to Dusty seriously is
he is he still alive why am I here I
don't even like Kate she doesn't even go
here in this recap in theory video we'll
be going over tons of new details and
you'll want to stick around till the end
of the video for the trailer sleuthing
section to see what exactly we're in for
in the final two episodes I've left time
stamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering and while you're
at it like And subscribe proceeds from
this video will be going directly to the
Red River Institute for children that
have killed their parents the title of
this episode is Jumanji and if you
haven't seen the movie A what are you
doing with your life and B you'll need
to know that it's all about being
transported into a different world so
just like Robin Williams gets trapped in
a board game so too do our characters
get trapped in Kate's mind mind it's
also fitting because Jumanji is the code
word kate uses for Rufus to bash his
balls in jumi at the end of episode 5 we
saw Kate give Andre his Memories Back
the first being him absolutely stomped
by Sam she'll end up giving everyone's
Memories Back with Emma being especially
grateful
also you're Billy butcher would be proud
I love the girls get it done poster a
reference to the female empowerment
campaign seen in the boys season 2 yeah
okay cool in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter showrunner Eric kryy
stated that this is a direct satire on
the contrived girl power moment in
Avengers end game the question then
becomes why would Kate work with shett
on wiping their memories well put
yourself in Kate's shoes or head you're
locked away for 9 years your parents
think you're a dangerous monster then
all of a sudden this woman comes along
telling you she can help she gets rid of
the voices in your head and you believe
she genuinely has your best interests at
heart so when she asks you to do some
wiping under the guise of it being for
the greater good you can kind of see
where she's coming from cuz I'm all
about consent what a total lie we're
going to learn a lot more about the
extent of Our Hero's Powers this episode
it was it just me or can Kate read
people's minds without touching them why
would you do this to us I'll never
forgive for this this actually has huge
implications going forward if true
that's an incredibly strong power I'm
talking Mel Gibson level thank you
you're welcome my little sweet ass Andre
blames hate for all the [__] that's
happened but it's Marie who reminds him
the real culprit is gulin I like how she
fidgets with her switchblade here it's
the same switchblade she used at Red
River in episode 1 and to cut herself to
sop Sam I'm interested if this blade has
any sort of significance to her but
again I usually look too deep into these
things Andre and Marie are in that same
room we saw the fire breather in last
episode and Andre uses the opportunity
to vent about Kate's betrayal and his
dad being a piece of [__] remember that
polarity knows about the woods and told
his son never to bring it up don't say
another [__] word about this Kate has
started to convulse something we saw
happen to her when she pushed too much
at the end of episode 2 luckily Marie is
here to save the day able to slow down
Kate's heart rate and stabilize her if
Marie can slow down a heart could she
stop one or perhaps make a heart race so
fast that it explodes last episode Dr
cardosa said that Marie's powers are
unlike anything he's ever seen her
ability sir the rarest I've ever seen
she doesn't understand how powerful she
really is and hints that she may be one
of the most powerful soups out there
imagine if Marie could stop the
heartbeats of everyone on the planet
obviously she's not that powerful yet
but it's a possibility in my trailer
breakdown section I'll go over how
Marie's power might be connected to
Victoria Newman the head popping soup
running alongside Robert Singer as his
vice presidential candidate down in the
woods Dr cardosa is proud to show off
the success of his virus here we see a
young young soup named Betsy this isn't
the first time we've seen Betsy who
scorched the food trolley lady in
episode 3 Betsy if you don't want dinner
keep it up she has some sort of fire and
electricity power but two days ago she
was injected with the virus and her
powers are almost non-existent for
cardosa this is a success a way to quote
compassionately control soups and this
success was largely in part to the
experiments done on Sam in my past
videos I've theorized that Dean Shetty
may have a hidden power but this is
looking less and less likely especially
considering the dean basically
greenlights a more deadly version of the
virus with the ability for it to be
contagious cardosa has made sure that
the virus can only attach to strains of
compound V found in the blood thus
regular humans will not be infected
maybe this is why Dr cardosa wanted
Marie as a test subject her ability to
control blood might prove useful in his
research this request was nixed by
Shetty who explained that Marie has a
mysterious benefactor I believe this
benefactor to be Victoria Newman but
more on that later in the video Kate's
powers are so great that she has
collectively gathered Andre Marie Jordan
and Dusty inside her mind as it slowly
shuts down if she dies so do they the
first memory they see is of young Kate
in episode three Kate told us how she
told her younger brother Caleb to get
lost not knowing that her powers had
manifested Caleb was never seen from
again here we see the aftermath of this
and how her parents were so afraid that
they basically locked her behind this
giant Ste door but don't worry Kate has
her imaginary friend soldier boy in fact
we can see a soldier boy poster for his
film hero seeking hero which he starred
alongside Crimson Countess and which can
be seen at the Stardust theater there's
also a poster for Crimson countess's
whiskey Sunrise a movie produced by The
Legend and a larger poster of which can
be seen in the boys season 3 along with
his amazing knock knck jokes knock knock
who's there go your face Soldier Boy
tells them Kate's head is unraveling and
all these lightning strikes they're
experiencing are blood vessels bursting
in her brain Soldier Boy does tell Andre
that Kate genuinely loves him and I'm
inclined to believe this is true
considering this is coming from Kate's
mind and while soldier boy dies to a
lightning strike here in the real world
he's locked up in this kind of cryosleep
under the supervision of Grace mallerie
if you've paid close attention you'll
even notice a soldier boy statue on
campus which has been vandalized and
painted red because VA news has deemed
him a Russian traitor back at the
drive-in Sam enjoys some delicious the
Deep VA twists which look like basically
Twizzlers and I thought it was pretty
funny that there's a polarity movie
poster and crane game behind Emma and
Sam polarity has the power of magnetism
and there's definitely some magnetism
between these two the last time Emma and
Sam were together Emma had no memory of
him so this is a rekindling of their
relationship one which ends with Sam
losing his virginity remember this is a
guy who's been locked up for years with
only Queen mave Comics to alleviate his
needs and I got to hand it to Emma not
only is she super understanding but this
has got to be a step up from hanging on
some dude's ding-dong Sam also sees Emma
as a puppet but remember no King shaming
I like how dusty has just kind of been
sucked up with him we still don't know
what his power is and because the others
can't use their powers in Kate's mind
we'll never know what it is pretty
ironic that Dusty will get vaporized
into dust by Golden Boy now if he died
in Kate's mind did he die in real life
the others don't seem too concerned
about him after they get out of Kate's
head we bear witness to Kate's first
meeting with Dean Shetty Shetty is
incred rly kind to Kate allowing her to
touch her with her gloves off this might
be the first person she's touched in 9
years as Kate said an episode 3 that her
parents never touched her after the
incident it's also here that the dean
starts Kate on medication medication she
says will stop the voices in her head we
saw Andre give Kate this medication in
episode 3 after she convulsed and now
that he knows it was given to her by the
dean he looks a bit awkward here what is
this medication yes it stops the voices
in her head but does it do anything else
how much has it suppressed her powers I
also like how the pill is blue just like
compound V and knowing the dean wants to
take away these soup's powers are there
any long-term effects of it Kate's
thirdd memory involves her first meeting
with Golden Boy remember that Kate
initially majored in crime fighting
which is where it looks like she met
Luke but in episode 4 during Tech
Knight's interrogation I mean interview
we learned she switched Majors to Hero
management with the plans on becoming
golden boy's manager Golden Boy confirm
runts Andre here this isn't a memory of
Kate's at all and as we'll soon learn
Kate has Blended all their memories and
fears together Andre's big secret is
that he was seeing Kate even when she
was with golden boy that sure must have
made those mesmerizer marathons the
three of them had a bit awkward with an
enraged Golden Boy on the loose and
their powers useless in Kate's mind the
three rushed to another memory this time
of Jordan's I personally think this
secret is the worst here we find out
that Jordan knew Professor Brink was
drugging Luke hell the guy has caught
literally with a syringe in his hand and
instead of helping their friend they put
one of these gas masks on him the same
kind used to incapacitate Sam and
soldier boy at the end of season 3
Jordan doesn't question Brinks
explanation that Luke is being given
special treatments to make him as
powerful as homelander in fact Jordan
asked to have them too but to Plate
their concerns Brink offers Jordan His
ta position this means this event
happened prior to Marie arriving at
gulan and requesting acceptance into the
crime fighting course just how long did
Jordan know this was going on it looks
like Jordan's fear here is that they'll
always be a coward if they're going to
grow as a character they'll need to
stand up to Dean Shetty and do what is
right taking a much more light-hearted
tone we find Emma and Sam Post puppet
sex Sam thinks it was Neato but does the
typical it's not you it's me excuse but
in his defense Sam does have a lot of
issues he has to deal with if he's going
to get through this and Emma wants to be
there for him when he does even though
Sam says the two should run away
together Emma knows this isn't the
answer she says there are people who can
help them back at the woods we get one
of Kate's most disturbing memories she
was actually in the labs when Luke was
being transfused with Sam's blood not
only that but she wiped his memories
dozens if not hundreds of times to make
him forget that he even had a brother
maybe this is why when Luke sees a
vision of Sam in episode 1 Sam is very
young this is what Sam would have look
like the last time Luke remembered him I
also think it's pretty ironic that they
lay on homelander pillows since Homeland
was basically raised in a lab now there
are a lot of weird things going on with
the woods that don't make sense for
example Brink says that he is
transfusing Luke with Sam's blood to
make him stronger if we believe that to
be true then why are they simultaneously
creating a virus that will kill all
soups there's definitely something more
going on here as Sam tells us at the end
of the episode Shetty was quote doing
other stuff to Luke too I'm getting a
bit ahead of myself here but why would
VA want to create a virus that destroys
the very thing they make money on that
is unless Dean Shetty has gone Rogue now
I can see vot wanting to create a virus
that suppresses or terminates one's
power that means they could have some
leverage if a soup were to get out of
hand homelander but killing all soups
with a contagious virus does not seem
like something vot would want this gives
Credence to the dean shett has gone
Rogue Theory we already know that she
has the capacity to lie to VA CEO Ashley
Barrett covering up that Sam escaped the
woods she manipulates Kate with batting
an eyelash and she has no issue with
blackmailing others to get what she
wants like what she did to Tech knite
and last episode she basically told
cardosa he has nowhere else to go after
all these brutal tests he's done here
but what motive would Dean Shetty have
in betraying her employer and creating
such a virus we have almost no
information about the dean's past other
than she had a child you have a
daughter I did it's brought up once and
never again what if VA or Sue SS were
responsible for the death of her child
maybe she gave compound V to her
daughter and it killed her remember that
adults have a 20% survival rate when
taking compound V hence why it's
normally given to Children where there's
a higher chance of surviving maybe
Shetty just hates soups because they
killed her daughter there are a lot of
unknowns here but it really seems like
Shetty has ulterior motives the final
memory belongs to Marie and like Jordan
exposes her greatest fear outside a top
translucent statue sits a doorway the
same door way her mother broke down the
fateful day Marie killed her parents in
the corner is her sister Annabeth who
claims that no matter how hard Marie
tries to be a hero she'll be nothing
more than a murderer Annabeth's current
whereabouts have been a secret so far
she was said to be put in the Foster
system away from Marie after the murders
but in episode two we learned from Haley
Miller that they contacted Annabeth who
said she wanted nothing to do with her
sister as Shetty says who knows if it
was even true Marie Kate and the others
need to realize all of this is isn't
their fault almost every single problem
they face is a direct result of their
parents injecting them with compound V
as Kate bluntly puts it it is not your
fault your parents shot you up with a
dangerous drug when you were a baby to
make a buck off you Kate releases them
from her mind but she wants to stay
asleep forever something Andre even
though he hates Kate right now can't
accept Kate finally has a choice in her
life and she can't just throw it away
they all awaken back in the real world
their powers and memories intact Emma
and Sam have arrived you have sex hair
and of course as Kate has just been
through this emotionally draining
traumatic event Sam has come to exact
his revenge to him Kate is the woman who
made his brother forget about him who
was complicit in his imprisonment so no
wonder he's mad it's Emma however who
calms him down instead of taking his
anger out on Kate who was also a victim
of Shetty they need to go after her
themselves this is where we find cardosa
and Shetty overlooking the dead body of
Betsy who after being given a slightly
more Cal concentrated version of the
virus has died with huge open blisters
and pules all over her body for cardosa
this is terrifying but for Shetty this
is amazing she wants him to make it so
that it's contagious something if
released into the world could kill every
soup on the planet with that we move on
to our trailer sleuthing section where
we take a look at the season's trailers
to theorize what might be in store for
us in the future it looks like Dr
cardosa is hard at work creating that
infectious virus we'll see his
reflection here as three separate
prisoners are exposed to an infected it
looks like one of them is dead one is
coughing and the other wanting out this
one here looks as though they're on
death's door and experiencing the same
blisters as Betsy there's some sort of
protest on campus with students carrying
signs with things like Heroes United
stomp super haate and Newman remember
that Victoria Newman has run a strong
anti-p campaign and her powers are still
unknown to the public we still don't
know her true motives something that may
be revealed later in the season season
of gen V or in season 4 of the boys
Victoria will make an appearance at this
town hall where both Pro and anti-p
protesters can be seen it looks like it
gets a little out of hand as one
attendee uses her super scream attack in
the redband trailer Victoria says to
someone this is your shot at real power
it then cuts to Marie Victoria Newman is
my number one guest as being Marie's
special benefactor the two both attended
Red River they both killed their own
parents by accident grew up in the
Foster system and both have power that
involve controlling blood we've seen
Marie fall sway to the Allure of power
especially in episode 2 so it would make
sense that Victoria would try to get
marur on board by saying this is her
shot at it here we see Marie Jordan Emma
and Sam hiding here in the back they're
in someone's house which I think could
be Dean shett the windows here have that
same crisscross pattern we've seen in
her house plus there are some teapots
which she loves to drink Sam looks to be
in the dorms at gulin alongside Emma he
has pretty much nowhere to go so maybe
they disguise him and ask him to lay low
even though we'll see him parting it up
in the hallways this freeze breath guy
makes a cool slip and slide floor we
still haven't seen this shot of a
shocked Ashley Barrett in the recently
released gen V boys crossover video it
looks like she makes her way to campus
here with director Adam pork who she
porked in season 3 something happens
that make them plug their ears it makes
me think of that sound device used
against Andre in episode 2 but that's
only supposed to work against soups
either the Gang has re-engineered one of
these things or another soup like the
scream girl is causing it polarity does
an interview with trusted VA news anchor
Cameron Coleman we can see the name here
in the background this might tie into
Victoria's visit as we'll see a man who
appears to be Cameron Coleman doing the
town hall with her roof is here just
jamming along I wonder how is Dicks
doing here we see the gulan metal doors
trapping some students inside I've long
suspected that gulan doubles as a prison
we've already seen Andre close these big
metal plates over the windows and just
look at the security Marie passes to get
in now it looks like there are some
prisoners who make it out of the woods
like this girl here with laser beams
coming out of her eyes she wears the
same gray sweater and pants like the
other inmates now that we know there is
some form of contagious virus it begs
the question will it get out into the
real world if these prisoners Escape
we'll see Jordan fight what might be the
same or different lasery girl outside
although this time the woman is wearing
different clothing that's pretty much it
for the trailers now I turn it over to
you what do you think will happen in the
weeks ahead I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @
thinkstory YT until next time remember
holy
[__] a lot is
happening